well today we have a bunch of working
women it's not only I'm sure there's
many but if you're to pick one person
the most influential woman in your life
what who would you say that is there's
this is a two-parter so number one would
be my mom who's been such a she's been
the quintessential rock of the family
and gone through tough times yeah I'm
the pebble she's my rock but so I would
say her butt and then certainly after
being with Lauren my wife now for over
ten years and just when I watched her
over the years and certainly with our
babies and her doing everything that you
possibly can to make sure that it's as
normal as it could possibly be our
babies have good perspective and
handling the household handling me which
could be a big payment but our life the
complexities that that brings and also I
was talking to her last night so we
moved in the past three years since our
babies have been born over 25 times for
my work in three years now when I say
we've moved she's moved like the babies
in the house and the dogs and the things
like that just and I look at her I'm
like you are my superwoman so what
happened
[Applause]
no I mean I guess I've traveled on the
road for years but at least it's one bus
everywhere right yeah it's like a home
base but oh my gosh okay I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this